there's this website livinginthepass.com
it's been run by this guy philip lord
since the 90s it's this kind of amazing
time capsule of what the internet used
to be a bunch of html web pages
connected with hyperlinks pixelated clip
art the papyrus font
it's a chronicle of one man's passion
projects
lord's model building endeavors deep
dives into his family history
and someone named henry rogers an artist
known for impressionist-style paris
street scenes who lord became obsessed
with tracking down because when you look
closer at henry rogers paintings things
don't really add up the signatures for
example
sometimes henry
sometimes the french henri
and when you try to search for henry
rogers online there's no information
about the painter himself it's almost
like he only exists in these paintings
of paris the more i read lord's website
the more i wanted to know who really
made these paintings
it's a puzzle that led me from the paris
street art scene to an ai art center in
cleveland and to drop 300 on ebay
all to try and answer the question
who is henry rogers
[Music]
henry rogers paintings are pretty easy
to come by online
and it doesn't take long to become
familiar with the core elements of his
paintings there's usually this blue
roofed building next to this reddish one
both with cloth awnings and across the
street another blue roofed building next
to another reddish one sometimes this
street leads to a paris landmark like
the eiffel tower
sometimes it doesn't you'll always see a
tree or a row of trees and along the wet
rainy looking street faceless blobs of
people who all seem to be walking away
from the viewer
they're almost entirely done with a
painting knife rather than a brush this
technique adds texture to paintings and
can result in little detail it's a style
that calls back to french impressionism
an art movement that was popular in
europe in the late 1800s with the most
famous artists working in paris
at this point you might be thinking okay
so this is kind of like a parisian bob
ross someone who developed a technique
to mix and match elements quickly like
the classic rogers tree and managed to
produce a large number of similar
looking paintings over their lifetime
that could be true but before we throw
out any theories let's lay out
everything we know about henry rogers
and let's start online
living in the past.com is still the only
place on the internet that's devoted any
research into these paintings philip
lord told me that the obsession had
faded for him and he didn't want to give
an interview but he gave me permission
to use his website as a starting point
for my own investigation lord's search
for the elusive french artist began with
this painting which hung on the wall of
his childhood home in upstate new york
but when he tried to find info about the
artist who signed it nothing turned up
lord had a bunch of theories for who
rogers might be but generally they fall
into three potential buckets one henry
rogers was a very busy french painter
working in paris sometime in the 70s and
80s who spelled his name two ways two
henry rogers was a group of artists
making these paintings together and
using a pseudonym to make them seem more
valuable and on the more extreme end
three henry rogers paintings were
mass-produced likely by so-called
factories in china where artists
methodically create similar looking
paintings
to figure out if rogers was one person
lord started meticulously dissecting
images of henry rogers paintings he
found online ones that turned up in san
diego and toronto but also in germany
and one in south africa several of the
frames were stamped made in mexico on
the back like three of the ones i bought
he compared signatures between henry and
henry searched google street view to
find where a painter might have stood
and diagrams the shifting perspectives
of the classic rogers street determining
that its basic layout looks like this he
also looked into similar artists like
caroline burnette another prolific
painter with a similar style and
similarly murky origins when he
considered the close resemblance of the
knife techniques for henry and henry and
that the paintings very often seem to
depict the same street from various
positions
he landed here
in his opinion henry rogers was one
artist working in the streets of paris
sometime in the 1970s and 1980s who may
have exported his work for sale in
foreign markets which helps explain the
wide distribution and the mexican frames
but philip lord never really had a
smoking gun and he gave up trying to
find more about henry rogers in 2011. so
when i picked up the case in 2022 i
wanted to start with a fresh source one
that philip hadn't tried
a paris street painter let me show you
some paintings really quick yeah they're
good but it looks like they've never
been in paris
jerome is an artist who works in the
part of paris henry rogers would have
been working in the historic monmouth
district street artists have been
painting in montmartre for hundreds of
years
many of them sell their work off in
scenes of paris or portraits to tourists
jerome works nightly in the most famous
hub in montmartre for painters it's a
square called place duterte he told me
it's not uncommon for people to sell or
exhibit paintings in paris they claim
were made in place duterte but weren't
he said they'll even often be signed
with a fake french name like dupont
durong
and there's no dupont duran plus duterte
but it looks like exotic when i asked
him about the streets themselves and the
angles philip lord had painstakingly
diagrammed okay look this is the same
country
street i have
never in paris you can see this kind of
angle but they put the effect out to do
like a nice background it's like a
fantasy jerome thinks the made in mexico
stamp on the frames the imagined
perspectives and the varying signatures
point to henry rogers being a mexican
artist or group of artists selling these
paintings as cheap decor items made to
look like a souvenir from place to tear
it looks like the taste of paris like
the authentic way the romantic way
at this point i felt like there had to
be something philip and i were both
missing and that jerome couldn't see
over skype some clue too tiny to notice
by just looking at the paintings alone
or that needed to be seen up close by an
expert that's when i reached out to case
western reserve university in cleveland
a group of scientists and art history
experts there are using artificial
intelligence to help tell artists apart
based on microscopic differences in
brush stroke style they invited me to
their lab in cleveland to see if they
could tell me anything about my rogers
paintings
so we're looking for things that are
common across the paintings and we're
trying to control as many variables as
possible anna martin runs case western's
more center that's the materials for
opto electronics research and education
center so what i'm going to do is
measure out pieces of the painting i'm
going to do pieces of the sky and then
the trees she's scanning common elements
of each painting using this machine an
optical profilometer this tool could
help us figure out if certain elements
of these paintings were done by
different hands basically it shoots this
little dot of light onto the surface of
the painting and measures the distance
the light traveled when it bounces back
charting out microscopic changes in
height of paint
a single data point spans just 11
microns which is apparently very very
very small so it's the fraction of a
width of a human hair they called me two
weeks later with the results um so we
prepared a couple of slides these were
the scans that idna took
for their experiment the team scanned a
bunch of five millimeter patches from
three of my paintings and created a
detailed height map they used this data
to assign each painting a profile one
two and three then they fed different
unknown five millimeter sections of all
three paintings through the machine to
see if it could identify which painting
the sections came from basically if it
could connect a patch like this to an
entire painting and if it can do that
that's a clue that perhaps there are
different hands involved if it's the
same person and we tested this in the
past the machine basically fails at that
task because he can't distinguish the
patches
and roughly 90 percent of the time
the computer got it right
there were enough differences in
technique at a microscopic height level
to accurately identify which painting
was which
the fact that these paintings have their
own unique fingerprint is a strong case
for henry rogers being the name of a
workshop
some group of artists who were trained
to imitate each other almost perfectly
with nearly invisible differences
between the paintings
i let the team at case western keep my
henry rogers paintings for further study
this has also helped us in thinking
about how we're going to approach other
paintings etc so this has actually been
a very useful kind of exercise hopefully
it'll help get the machine closer to
identifying invisible fingerprints in
other more famous paintings
and now like philip lord before me i'm
closing up the case but with a lot of
new information
and having gotten just a bit closer to
finding out who henry rogers was
and henry if you're out there i love the
work
email me if you see this
[Music]
do
[Music]